Tương nghiệp mỹ phẩm của Kun vừa phát gia thù báo chiếc tức có mặt tại thị trường nghiệp bản.
Sự kiện này không chỉ có ý nghĩa với thương nghiệp của Kun mà còn đánh giấu mất quan trọng của mỹ phẩm viét trên bản đồ mỹ phẩm tỷ giới.
Dính tại khu vực chó á, nhật bản tưởng được mạnh rằng là thị trường khó tính bật nhất.
Người nhất có yêu cầu các khai về chất lượng sản phẩm và đặc biệt thân u hộ hàng lựa của mỹ dù nghiệp cũng rất cao.
Được biết đầy ra nhập vào thị trường này, Kun đã trải qua hơn 1 năm kìm viét chất lượng,
Kun như xem sẽ sự phù hợp của mỹ phẩm tự của Kun đối với lượng Mỹ phẩm tại đất nước này.
Tình đến nay, Kun đã hiện diện trên kệ của Aion Stein, N. Bà Tún, Tương Moth S, Amelican, Phamacy,
Sapuro, Dạc Stau, ở nếu nơi trên đất nước nhật, đang xong bối sẩm phẩm khu chỉ là công dụng hiệu quả cho lạnh ra phẩm máy thóc.
Mà còn là công dụng về nguyên nựa của nữ tự hạp ta phy.
Cuả bùi măng thật yếu và sự trên trọng sành cho thêm liên đăng được lĩnh tình hơn của nguyên dụng nghiệp bản.
Mình cảnh thị trường vệ phạm, Kun cũng đã sức hồ sân phẩm của bình đi mề bố cuốc gia và vùng lãnh phổ khác trên thế giới.
Trong những ngày cả nước đặc thân phóng về đại lĩnh nơi nghe nghe nghe thay ạng sinh,
đây cũng là một tí có tèc để chúng ta tưởng nhau tự hào về thương nghiệp của Việt Nam trên trường của bếng.